okay for those who are
joining us we are looking at some
wolverine language design
in preparation for the 13-1 release that
hopefully will be coming up fairly soon
looking at this is a season of design
reviews and this afternoons is about
visualization
right so it's it's a little bit smaller
than it usually is if you open
that new scaling functions you'll see
that a lot of functions are actually
affected
um okay well let's take a look at should
we start off with ternary plots yeah
let's do that sure
um
okay should i just open the page for
them
and is this runnable
yes
you know there's a
there's a um
uh
i don't know whether you pick this up
but there's a
these in physics these are sometimes
called darlitz plots
right usually using a right triangle i
think
was that right yeah that's right
actually yeah that's correct
i used to know dick darlitz he wasn't he
never liked me very much but so it goes
um
um
anyway so can we make a a a right
triangle version of this
presently no but it wouldn't be hard to
do
seems worth doing
this is a first um
there's a lot of variants of this
like you could have a ternary this
density plot you could have a contour
plot et cetera
a
3d plot
that many various examples should move
down to apps but
anyway
yeah it's way way way elaborate
so
this is a polygon with x y coordinates
which is being rendered
that is the polygon
with xyz vw
coordinates
okay
they're being defined in terms of
triples
this is really weird i don't understand
what this is
this is this has got okay i'm i'm just
totally confused here so
i'm going to ignore that
okay
okay so i mean if if i
in 3d
if i basically just make
um
if i say
uh
table
now
t t squared one plus t or something
what's a nice good i don't know let me
make a list as you figure
2t cosine
3t
i think you want odd numbers in both
coefficients don't you
you're telling me i want three fights
it's still a lizard whatever you give
yeah it's just that's interesting yes i
agree with you
okay so if i say parametric plot
3d of this
t zero two pi
okay fine that's lovely
okay so now what i want to do
you know what i'm going to do here i'm
going to make a table here
of this thing with
0.02
for example
and then that object i'm going to say
ternary list plot of that object
i'm really curious to see what this
looks like
it's called dimension reduction
i'm confused
well let's let's try going down to 0.002
it's kind of interesting actually
well anyway
um i mean
uh
yeah i don't really understand that
now i suppose if i were to put
a um
a helix here
what happens with negative proportions
correct
positive it's going to scale down so
they're still proportions
and negatives are going to get tossed
ah
oh i see
so if i did sine squared
put the square no
no no no no
that would be so cool if we could
it means the wrong way i think that's a
bug in mathematics it's a completely
inconsistent
okay that's a nice picture
what's a good example for you
okay
okay so what else is there to say about
this
right so the thing to
right i mean so for the people who are
watching who maybe aren't familiar with
these
so we're taking
three-dimensional data
and converting it to two dimensions by
you know basically dividing
things by their sums
um
and then we get a thing that can be
we convert it into proportions
and
because everything adds up to one after
that division
we can basically reduce the dimension by
one
we can switch to x y
using that you know equality
and
so
um
and also if people on the stream
use them then that would be very useful
for us to find out in what context and
in what the applications are
so we've seen a lot of them
like in chemistry
uh
yeah science you know like nutrition
ratios or
soil ratios or
um
you know other other mixtures basically
right i think they used um
i mean phase diagrams i think for like
alloys and things use things like this
but a common case is
that um
uh is not
um
[Music]
is not these point plots but more
a
there's entire families of these right i
mean you get contours or
regions or
wait you can also just get a value can't
you uh well no that makes sense you've
got to have it's a parametric value
right and and
which will color every point in this
diagram
right i mean one of the things that's
related to this and one of the early
instances of this type of plot were
um like the chromaticity color
you know yes uh where your your three
corners are red green and blue and
you're blending
different proportions of those
by the way i just want to comment that
if you're going to give the grid
here by default i would make it a lot
lighter than this
and i'm not even sure you should give
the grid by default
and i also think these dots are a bit
small i don't really know whether
they're a standard size or not
um i think we've
can you evaluate dollar version just for
oh i actually never mind um i i agree
they're a little bit small we have a
separate branch that is bumping them up
um
that's not in
what happened what happened what
happened where did that go
why didn't i see an around there um
at the moment it is
not showing error bars although
you know it's still using the 0.7
but we aren't representing
uncertainty around the points
um i mean if you have uncertainty on all
three you know coordinates
you know for a point
then you end up with a little hexagon
you know yeah
uh type representation but we haven't
implemented that yet
okay
now
um but anyway so coming back to your
comment about the grid lines at the
moment we have the grid lines turned on
because
i think it makes it
a little bit easier to read or at least
in some
contexts so each of those grid lines
corresponds to
a fixed ratio between two of the
elements
yes
um
and i think it's easy to read
conceptually i think once people are
using these kinds of plots they know
that they're using these kinds of plots
therefore i would i would remove the
good lines just like you could say well
it makes it easier to read an ordinary
list plot if you include gridlines
i don't claim i claim this argument you
know once if you're not used to these
plots then you need gridlines if you're
not used to a ordinary list plot you
might need grid lines too
perhaps
um
we we can turn the grid lines off by
default that's
not an issue and
um i mean the other thing that's
that i'll point out
um about these plots is these are you
know one of the ones that is using the
new axis objects
um
which and why do these i mean i'm just
looking at you know it's a hairy animal
yeah and let me let me just um
it's got hairs and i want to look at it
why didn't that work
i'm not sure what you did
i'm just pressing command plus
why doesn't it work to magnify that
because that only changes font size
right
it's not magnification
oh
okay
well
how do i magnify a single cell here
just click it and drag it out
no no no no it's not going to do what i
want it's not going to do what i want
what i want is to magnify the hairs
okay because right now you can't see it
very well but those hairs are horizontal
on that side
but the creature has has basically you
know it's it's it's um
the tick marks are direction
yes i i can see that but they're
directioned by
what are they directioned by mean so
these ones are horizontal here these
ones are
in the direction of these lines here
right i mean so like consider that
horizontal point eight on the top left
okay right so there's two grid lines
that come into point eight
yep
only one of those grid lines actually
corresponds to point eight
the other grid line corresponds to point
two on the bottom right corner
well i i don't understand that comment i
mean i the i'm i'm saying the text
right what determines the orientation of
the text
right they're not the grid line
that's just what brett said
the grid line associated with point
eight is the one that follows the
orientation of the tick oh i see
okay
kind of kind of pet you know
kind of pedantic but nice
right
we are kind of pedantic people
exactly and you know but i want people
to be able to look at this and
interpret it correctly
right sandra is commenting can we also
get grid lines that fan out from a
corner
signifying that one of the ratios is
kept constant while the other fraction
is adding
well keeping
the fraction
we don't have those grid lines at the
moment
um we could have a symbolic
i mean i was thinking about that that's
a really
that's an interesting idea but i have a
design idea of how we can incorporate it
if we allow for sort of named classes or
gridlines
i see
which we probably should do at some
point
now i don't remember
why did darlitz plots why are they right
angle triangles do you know
i don't remember off the top of my head
i remember what they are
just so you know that the
uh
you know
the decay of a certain kind of particle
into three particles has the feature
that
the momentum of the three particles have
to add up to a constant
right
energies actually yeah
um
right so i'll make two comments
um one is
i
remember reading that
um right angle triangles are used
in cases where there's
a significant bias toward one of the
components
where it's not point you know where it's
not 20 30 50 but it's 97 one percent
two percent
um
and there's a reason for that that i
don't remember
um
the other thing that i'm going
that i wanted to mention is that
you know with ternary list plot it's not
a requirement of the data that that each
triple
has the same sum
yeah and um
yeah we're just
the normalization happens regardless of
that and so we end up in that state at
the end
but it doesn't have to start i think it
could very well be the case that these
plots were plotted as right triangles
just because that was the only easy
thing to plot
it's quite impossible too i'm not sure
that there's a significance to that
because i don't see any reason why this
wouldn't be a fine way to do it
the other thing i was going to ask you
is do you have a preference on
which
edges first and what order they go
around
i would think one two three
okay
what are you doing right now
one we're doing that order
um we should probably flip the axis
directions i think
one well okay
so the bottom one
zero one and we go from zero to one
left to right and the next one should go
from zero to one
from bottom to top yep and then zero to
one down that way
i would think
okay i mean you should look at what
other people have done on this but that
would it it's
mixed all over the place
right so let's just decide that i mean
unless but can i suggest that you take
some of these things like this
that are kind of well understood
geometric configurations and make sure
they're not too stupid but if you do
that
you see what i'm saying
i'm not sure i i mean it's just going to
be a rotational reflection well
just check it okay
but it doesn't make that doesn't
fragment i mean
and this business with negative values i
don't know there's nothing to be done
about those
i mean if you have negative values
then i mean what happens is they would
end up
drawing outside of the triangle
and i'm not sure if other stuff would
break at the same time but
yeah well that that's not
reasonable anyway but
you know sandra is commenting that that
clockwise and anti-clockwise would be a
nice
i i think if you really want it
let's see if you wanted another
orientation
how would you get it
is everything just the negative
well i mean so the
i mean conceptually the you know one
parameterization for this
is you tell us where you want the three
vertices
you know and you go in that order and
you go in that order and if you want you
know your dollars plot you say zero zero
one zero
zero one
and if you once yeah i get it like an
obtuse triangle for some reason
i think that would be nice
i mean in a sense that's like a plot
range it's a ternary plot range
in effect
well i mean plant range is different
i mean this supports plot range you know
so no i understand that but i mean plot
range is kind of telling you where
what
yeah you're right it's different you're
right it's different
um what would the option be called
ternary plot corners
i mean to be honest i'd probably
do it as a method option and
no no no no no no let's okay not
necessary it's not necessary i mean we
could it could say ternary plot corners
that's not going to mean anything other
than that
right
so ternary plot corners it is
okay
and and by the way
i mean you could have
arrow quotes equilateral
well clockwise equilateral
you know equilateral would be one thing
and then you could allow clockwise uh
equilateral and counterclockwise
equilateral
and then we have our dalet string and
yeah
possibly we don't necessarily need those
kinds of strings i i i would say that
the ones you know by the time it isn't
equilateral
you're probably going to compute whether
where the thing is supposed to go
and for the case of um
a right triangle it's obviously
particularly easy to compute that
right
okay easier than equilateral
yeah right
okay
let's keep going here to visualization
scales
all right see how this works okay where
do i go to understand this
nominal scale and ordinal scale
and so so first of all scaling functions
you know scaling functions they've just
add we've added them to a huge number of
more functions in fact now
most functions if not all functions
pretty much support them
bar chart
the ones that don't are
getting far
few and far between
um
array plots for example does not yet
um
okay so let me just understand for a bar
chart when you have a scaling function
you can have a okay vertical scaling
function determines the height of the
thing but the horizontal scaling
function
the doesn't do anything i mean there's
no concept of a horizontal scaling
function for bar chart
right
it just takes a single scaling function
which affects the length of the bar
but we have a function called rectangle
chart where you can do that
right okay
all right nominal scale
okay so you should open both of these to
nominal and ordinal
at the same time
and put them side by side kind of
so these are both
categorical
yes i understand
the difference is
ordering the other one doesn't
exactly
so
one nominal is mainly used
to um
well name things like classes
uh products etc
can you say what height at what height
nominal will be yes
nominal no
ordinal you have control over
what the categories correspond to in
terms of what why does why do you need
nominal i mean aren't they going to be
given in the order that you specified
them anyway
so nominal allows
an automatic set
where you say i have nominal data and
it's just going to pull whatever it sees
you know in that coordinate
um
if that makes sense sorry say it again
yeah i mean nominal we support your
nominal of automatic
which
doesn't require you to list out the
settings ahead of time
i see actually i get it
so it will then what order will it put
them in
whatever order it comes across them
in the data
i see
whereas ordinal is always a
ordinal you have to specify what the
things are because you have to give it
another
why is that not the transpose of that
why does it not say totally dissatisfied
minus one and things like that
there are forms that allow that
what do you mean
so you mean i could also have the one
argument case
right so
well this is category and value as an
association
but you're not showing me here
the pair
category that
we do not have well okay so the issue
with
giving the pair
is that
you then have to distinguish between
a category that is a list of two things
and
the category value specification
so
i see i suggest
wait a minute what do you mean the
category i see the category where the
name of the category is as a pair
right
i see yeah it's nice to be able to
support i agree
you know
we both know that you know there's been
other cases where it's like you know i
have things that naturally are lists
as objects
and they you know don't always get
supported as well because this is
meaning something else
um
ethan on our live stream is complaining
about all the types of
of charts that we do not
i'm have like what
like
uh job security
tree maps
tree maps would be useful
yes
although i think you know we're
introducing tree map as a symbol with a
different meaning but
i'm okay with that we'll deal
yes
um
an awful lot of these other ones
um
i don't know what else the
sankey charts
sure
we'll be rolling them out we i mean we
have prototypes of all these
might be worth depending on the time
scale for the prototypes it might be
worth putting the prototypes in the
function repository
i think some of them already have
you know maybe externally you know
submitted function repository
implementations
uh there's certainly stuff close to
sankey charts i don't remember stinky
chart is actually there yet but
um
i don't think tree map is
but so we might
put one in there
i mean the issue with tremap is
how you specify the data in a way that
isn't weird and cumbersome
exactly um because it's basically tree
data
well that's um then maybe we should use
our trees framework
yeah um
i think we need other ways to because a
lot of data
is probably going to come from
spreadsheets
and then this could be conventions
yeah
okay anyway let's look at what we're
supposed to look at
okay
so
scaling functions are ordinal scale okay
but so
i think you need to give in the examples
for goodness sake can you please give an
example where you can actually see the
data first
see what i'm saying yes um
because i don't know what the heck this
data looks like i have no idea what the
stage looks right yes that that
i mean
we did that
a little bit more carefully on the
nominal one
um
okay that's what it looks like so why
don't you do it with a b and c and
things
rather than trying to make it as an
application example on the at the
beginning but look you know how right
we're trying to balance
connecting people and
all right anyway you you can do it i
mean it's it's some
uh
okay so this is a regular list plot and
you're claiming it doesn't get itself
tangled up in any way so if i were to do
this
you're saying
what if i gave coordinates to these
things as well as their values x
coordinates can i do that
sure
okay so then what i say is
i say something like table
uh
you know
random
real
10
random choice
abc
okay now i say list plot
percent
scaling functions arrow
identity
none
will identity work no
what's that
uh no identity will not work
i don't think
now if i just say
ordinal scale do i need to say abc
yes
that's the simplest case
ignore the error messages
okay
that's nice enough
uh okay
all right and i can go ordinal
right so if i say
lovely is it right
it doesn't look like you've only got six
pairs of six possible combinations i
don't think that's right
i don't think it's right
oh i see i see icic your point is it's
filled everything up in yeah yeah
but so now if i were to do this instead
if i were to say
you could have a date there in the first
date and ordinal
this whoops
i goes to 30.
now i'm going to say let's plot
list point plot 3d
i don't know if we've tried that one
recently
and there's several where this doesn't
make as much sense i mean contour plots
list contour plot really wants to do
interpolation between things yeah i know
so that um
but actually i've got a different
problem here which is that that if i say
i think it's that same option value
things showing up option value option
name label values not found in defaults
for ordinal scale
right
so we know about that issue
it's all moving
it's all still in flux a bit
um
yeah but
there's going to be a lot of is
functions where
this isn't supported initially because
it's not clear what sense it makes
um
but list point 3d certainly yeah
that should work yeah
okay
um
just look at all of this
what the heck is this
possible properties
okay
what is this
so so basically
we
there are cases where we want
to be able to
[Music]
you know do the conversion you know from
the category to the value or the value
to the category or
whatever
and rather than you know that you know
possibly hide this you know and do it in
an undocumented way i don't understand
what this is doing category
of value
see
ordinal scale of that category for that
value i guess that's right
okay
now the labels
i understand you have to repeat the
categories and the second element to yes
you don't have to i mean the one above
it
i see allows you to not you know do it
um
that last statement
allows two things
one is
um
you know it allows you to specify labels
for every category
um but also it means that if for some
reason
there's only you know a handful of
categories that you need to relabel
yeah by the way i think in this usage
you should give the two arguments here
cats vowels or something um it could be
one or two arguments which is why it's
dotted
there's not an ambiguity with the second
argument being a an association
um
we don't support
okay i mean so in the case of where
you're giving the association for the
vowels
that's already in the first argument the
first argument form
yes
um and and so there isn't an ambiguity
um
right
um
okay but anyway what
um one of the use cases that
the labels
makes i think especially interesting is
that
depending on
how your data is represented
you know wherever you're getting it from
it's
relatively common that your categories
are one two three four
yes
and
you can leave your categories as one two
three four and then just say one is cat
two is dog
yeah i get it
um
okay
all right so this is ordinal scale let
me look at nominal scale here i think i
get this
and
you're saying
i think you should allow nominal scale
open close here
okay
um
so what you're saying is
if i were to do percent eight
by the way it's not 100 obvious to me
that this ordering of
first one at the bottom is right it's
not what i would expect
i mean so it gets interesting
i mean because
i mean personally i'd rather not have to
that's interesting what that just did is
interesting
that's fine
i mean if that's how i have to get it so
be it
what do you mean
sorry leads down abc
do
percent eight
you know all
comma two
[Music]
and just look at what the you know the
sequence of things in
right you you hit c's then b then a
purely
it just happened to show up in the order
that you like
um
because it hit the c first
okay is there a sorting function in
nominal scale
there is not
um
and
[Music]
what i what i was going to say is that
the
order that you like
you know for mapping
categories to values
is different would be different for
the x and y value directions definitely
um
and
so look i think reading down the page is
kind of important
okay
i mean i think i i
uh
you know if you go from dissatisfied to
satisfied i think you want the satisfied
on top so that's a confusing thing
but that's an ordinal scale
yeah all right
and there you're saying you know bottom
to top what the ordering is yeah i
understand
um
yeah that's right but then this nominal
scale thing it's got to read the other
way it's got to read in the order that
you gave it
i think well now we will have to add you
know some mechanism for
[Music]
well i'm just trying to think about
saying i think
i think there are cases in which you
want it sorted
now i mean i guess you can do that by
just saying you know uh
nominal scale of um
you know
take the values and um
union them
right and then it will give you the
sorted nominal scale
okay
so do we have anything else that
does an internal sorting
along the lines of what we're looking
for i'm sure there's things with sorting
functions yes
right
i think what is it called
what just has those
i'm sure we have things that have
ordering functions um
hey i've got a question here if i say
something like come
okay here we go now i want to say list
plot
of that
oh well that works
how long has that been working
you mean where it gets the dates on the
x-axis yeah 13 now
did we talk about that in the blog post
about 13 00
i'm pretty sure we did
i mean it was definitely one of the
features in scaling functions that we
were discussing
yeah i'm not sure i really internalized
what it means
that's lovely
okay
so no more dateless plot
have we made that clear on the dateless
plot page
i mean dateless plot why would you use
dateless plot
uh date list plot
still allows things that
you know it has like the two argument
form where you can specify the date
ranges separately from
the values as a list of heights
um
that's the second usage statement for
dateless plots
at equilibriums i see that where i say
for example here
i
say i say
um
i'm not sure you want percent 21 there
but
i want the time series
well i mean but the syntax is a non-time
series input
you know this is stateless plot um
oh god why is stateless plot
framing it by default and this plot is
not
okay but so so what i was trying to do
here
um
what is it
that what is that it could have like why
isn't that auto completing
why would it's
what would you expect it to
auto-complete to
i thought that that second argument what
what's dates back
like a start stop
step type thing
okay
i mean it's like a date interesting it's
a basic example you know automatic today
you know
and then day i mean make one of those
today
okay i guess it did make one of them
today um
i don't understand this
i don't know
well because you have a time series in
the first argument so
you give date val
you give dates replacement 21 with
random real
okay or take the
you're saying that's the interpretation
take the values out of your time series
now you get the values only and you've
removed us
okay i get it i get it i get it
so that's the positioning that's that's
essentially
i mean what we have is this thing
uh you know data range that we use in
array plot for example
and in list plot
to do what the data range
is a mapping
it tells you what the what course you
know what x values correspond to the
first value
in a list and what so by default they
are one two three four kind of like a
list
but if you don't want them to be one two
three four you want them to be x-min to
x-max
equally spaced
okay
i see this is what for defaulted
i don't understand this example here
oh i see this i do
it's maybe not the best
i was gonna say the examples actually if
you probably have too many points
well also also this yes this is a subtle
i mean it should be more obvious what's
going on
yes you should change that example
okay
in any case
okay
uh
and for nominal scale and ordinal scale
we were
planning to make them um experimental
for thirteen one
um probably a sensible idea
um
i mean i i
yeah i mean what i'm wondering to myself
is whether there end up being functions
like you know categorical list plot and
so on but they may not need to be
hopefully there won't need to be
um i mean i think it's
still nice to have some of these common
cases as
their own functions
um like datelistplot or how we still
have the log flots
yeah the log parts are useful
um
and list line plot is useful too
yep
exactly
list step plot
yeah that's useful too um
okay
uh how are you doing at the um
plot arrays
which i've essentially never used
because they firefight them just utterly
confusing
so say that again
plot arrays of plots
oh multi-panel yes
we have no update in this release
but we flow them in in 30 now we flowed
them in in a lot of uh
i still find them super confusing i
would think that they're an outer
wrap-up
okay we're going to do an update i hope
in the next release
where uh some of these ways that you can
construct your own
graphics grid and so on have updates but
the documentation is not caught up and
they need to
actually
you know another round
we need to do a static upgrades to them
okay
but so you are having what sort of i'm
curious just know what sort of wrapper
you have in mind i just want a a you
know a graphics grid type wrapper where
i give it a bunch of plots and it
automatically deals with putting their
scales together i don't want to have it
i gotcha okay i don't want to have
something where i'm going from the
inside out i want to go from the outside
in
i think and have it sync everything up
yes
um
because i think about it as making a
bunch of separate plots i don't think
about it as making some kind of weird
multi-paneled you know i plot the same
you know you know i think about
yeah
i mean yeah we want to provide both and
but it's just the graphics grid side
lags behind right now and needs to catch
up and we need to do
that that thing needs to be sort of
modernized
um
and we also need to do some aesthetic
upgrades
right
yep remind me again in the um thing
where you have two different plot scales
how do we do that again multi-axis
arrangement
oh boy
that's the that's the symbol
yeah
why didn't
i guess that work
arrow down into the completion well it's
oh god that's not how any autocomplete
in the world works come on
that's how it works in
the notebook
no it doesn't it's not how it works well
i see i see what you're saying what but
i don't think it's right here it's not
how people
search things i tend to agree with you
okay so let's let's complain and let's
try and get that fixed
yep i mean it also doesn't help that
you know the
appearance of
what is selected in that drop down right
what is this very subtle
yeah anyway
okay
by the way why should that be separated
that shouldn't be separated
in the in the documentation right that's
part of the same example
do you understand what i'm saying
sorry i didn't see the separator over
zoom yeah so
it shouldn't be that why did this get a
roof
it shouldn't have a roof
because it looks really weird to have
three sides of the box
yeah
so if i say
frame arrow none
will i still get a roof
i
don't
remember
yeah i think that roof really should be
blown off at least in certain cases like
this one
okay minor comment
uh
okay sanders asking about a graphics
grid v2
where he can combine contour list plot
etc oh there's all kinds of combinations
that you want to sync up
um yeah
no so you want to tie things together
and i'll see i see well we're on a
projection from the list plot 3d
down to a contour plot and so on
exactly
um
okay
uh okay well let's see is there anything
else we need to go over here this looks
some
this was an easy review
and right on time
indeed
what's going on
how are you what ultimate universe are
we living in
the um
is this this is all the background
information
yeah
there's there's many rounds of things
that we will actually do with
categorical um stuff categorical data
categorical processing and so on so this
is the beginning and not very far from
the end
okay but i mean things like the uh the
satisfaction scale with smileys and
things i mean are we getting icons for
that and so on
uh
i don't know i mean i think most of
those you could do with you know emojis
yeah well fair enough but i mean there's
an icon data that we would probably want
to have that allows right i mean i was
going to say we could add some
you know more icons for
i think so for eye contact things if
there is
i mean all this works just fine with
icons right now if you use it you know
yeah i understand yeah i was gonna say
if you go to nominal scale
i think we have it one of the examples
actually is using icon data um although
it's using foods instead of
um
that one
that's cool
that's very nice
i mean it'd be nice if you showed how to
get those icons
right
i mean in in um you know having the
satisfaction scale there and things like
that would be a nice thing
and perhaps we have string names for
some of the common scales so it's
nominal scale of quotes whatever it is
i think they're so all over the place
that yeah we went there stephen
there's no chance of hitting what
somebody's actually
okay fine fine fun fun yeah
okay
well cool no i mean this is very direct
and i understand this and this is clear
the only thing will be useful for people
to see is where on earth you get those
icons from
uh
right i mean i don't know what kinds of
sequences of icons because you've got to
have the data here agree with the
sequence of icons right
right i mean is that is that data a
bunch of a bunch of ice cream cones and
things
in this case that data is a bunch of ice
cream cones
there and actually more cups of coffee
but
um
yeah but you could have
you know those icons are the display
form
for
text or numbers or something or
right the labels
yeah no
i'm just
okay one question here which may not be
well formed
no i see for a graph
the labels are already nominal that is
the
labels of vertices are nominal yes they
don't have coordinates
right
and so
what you're doing here in some sense
with a nominal scale
is a one-dimensional graph layout of
some kind
of some kind
and
and
the thing is that that kind of data is
pretty abundant if you look like
in our databases of stuff or survey data
um
and so it's not always graph data
no i understand that
and
what this does is make
literally all visualization functions
available in some way
shape or form
that we have
right
no i'm just trying to understand because
i've i've long wanted a 1d graph layout
and i've i've built it a few times
yes
it's a i mean it's something which it
seems like one day would be useful
uh
anyway john s on the live stream is
pointing out that inputting emoji as
things to compute with is convenient
because you can
just type them these days on keyboards
and i don't know what the maybe probably
nobody here knows what the unicode
standardization is
between uh the emoji that you get on one
i mean they're just unicode right so
they will they will move over to other
platforms
they might be differently rendered but
they will move over
right and you know it may be that
it may show up as an unknown glyph on
some platforms depending on you know
what your version of your operating
system is or
[Music]
that sort of thing
well if that glyph has not been you know
if that glyph doesn't exist in the fonts
then you won't have it but otherwise
right but i mean there's nothing it's
not like
what is an ice cream cone on one
operating system will be an elephant on
another one
one would hope that
nobody has gone that extreme with their
renderings
yeah okay so i can imagine all kinds of
socio-political
types of um re-renderings of things oh
boy well i mean you do get you know
these things sometimes where it's like
you know how they represent
you know
some specific emoji
you know was
it feels different from one platform to
the other on whether it's a
mean laughing clown or a happy laughing
clown yeah i know i know um
right i can do that right this is one of
these um oh i can imagine all sorts of
horrors there but let's not go there
sandra is asking does this work for pie
chart to have
the the um
uh one would assume that if i said in
here if i took this and i said um uh
it's an interesting question i don't
know if we've tried pie charts
um i can't imagine that it works
i mean i don't know that it's right i
mean pie chart doesn't support scaling
functions wonder where those pink boxed
if you tell it um
never mind it's because
it's the message function
um
you're saying here if i say tally of
this
yeah
but this should label it with
what the heck is that uh
i'm not sure
what you want it
can you evaluate that tally outside i'm
wondering what
yeah i mean it's going to give a bunch
of coffee cups with it's it look it just
gives the wrong
it's just in the wrong form
yeah it's just in the wrong form so you
need the counts doesn't it yeah these
are counts so you can get the counts
right now all i have to do is labels
chart labels are automatic right right
right
and then i'll have a pie in the pie
chart
okay
that's the um
the
final
here i think it's time for us to wrap up
with that uh that's a good example by
the way because it is probably
um it's very nice
okay the pie gets a small pie wedge look
at that
okay great
all right very nice steph thanks a lot
talk to you later